in this video we're going to continue
talking about ac analysis and the
concept of impedance as the the ratio of
voltage to current
in an ac situation
and just as a reminder of the the
assumptions we've made for ac analysis
we've assumed that all of our signals
are of the form of
some kind of a sinusoid like that cosine
is the typical one we pick cosine omega
t plus some offset angle and we're also
going to use euler's equation
which says we can decompose our cosine
into two complex exponentials so
one of the complex exponentials is e to
the plus
j
omega t
plus phi
and
j multiplies both of them
plus
e to the minus
j
omega t plus phi
and when we use euler's theorem what we
do is we love putting these things
through differential equations so we
track each of these one at a time
through our circuits and typically what
i'll focus on is the the plus term but
the minus term all the math is the same
except there's that one little minus
sign
and so when we made up the concept of
impedance we assumed that v or i was of
this form
this complex exponential and that may
when we put that through our components
we came up with the idea of impedance
and
as a review for
a resistor
the impedance of a resistor turned out
to be just
r
that's the ratio of v to i in a resistor
and for an inductor
we decided z
of an inductor
was equal to
j omega l
and finally for a capacitor
of value c
z c equals
1 over
j omega c
so those are the three forms of those
are the three impedances of our our
three favorite passive components
and the units of these the units are in
ohms
r is measured in ohms that's the normal
ohm's law
and we use the same units for impedance
of inductors and capacitors so
this is in ohms and this is in ohms
that may seem a little funny that
because there's this frequency turbine
here but these this is what it is
so in the rest of this video i want to
look at qualitatively look at the value
of these impedances
and specifically look at what happens
when there's a range of values of the
omega term what happens at zero
frequency and low frequency and high
frequency and infinite frequency so
let's go ahead and do that
so we're going to look at the impedance
terms
at different frequencies and we'll
measure frequency as radian frequency in
this so let's let's talk about zero
frequency and we'll talk about low
frequency these are qualitative
boundaries we'll talk about high
frequency and let's talk about infinite
frequency
so we're going to build a little chart
here
all right so these are the value of
omega here
and now we'll do our components i'm
going to do first we'll do our resistor
and we're going to fill in the table for
zr
and we know that equals r
so at any frequency r is just r couldn't
be simpler
at zero frequency which is just a d
called dc or a battery
r is r
at any low frequency
r is r r is r at infinite frequency so
there's no dependence on frequency in r
so now what now let's do
the inductor
and we decided that z
of an inductor was
j
omega
l
and let me do something very specific
i'm going to do
i'm going to get rid of this j i'm going
to basically say i want to just look at
the magnitude of the res of the
impedance
if we just look at the magnitudes the
magnitude of
z inductor
is
omega l
so now let's fill our table in for omega
l
so when omega is zero
the magnitude of the impedance is zero
for an inductor
and when the frequency is low when omega
is low
the impedance is going to be relatively
low and as the frequency gets high
then omega l becomes a larger number so
it becomes high
and if the frequency if we let the
frequency go to infinity
then omega becomes infinity and this
becomes infinity
so we see in an inductor from low
frequency to high frequency the
impedance of the inductor goes from zero
up to infinity
all right let's fill in the last one
here
here's our capacitor
and the z of a capacitor
equals 1 over j omega c
and the magnitude
of the impedance is just one over omega
c
all right so let's plot that out what is
one over omega c
when omega is zero well it's infinity
and what if omega is a small number if
omega is a small number
then this is a large number
this is a high number
and if
the frequency gets very high the higher
omega gets the smaller the magnitude of
z gets
so we get low here you see it's
anti-symmetric
with the inductor
and finally if we let the frequency go
to infinity
one over infinity times c is what is
about
is zero
with this chart i can show you some of
the words that we use some of the sort
of slang words or jargon words that we
use in electrical engineering to
describe the behavior of
l and c at different frequencies so as
we said r is r at any frequency so
resistance is constant
in inductor it changes over frequency
over this big range of frequency and at
zero frequency or low frequencies the
impedance is very low so this leads to
the expression we say an inductor looks
like a short
an inductor looks like a short at low
frequency at zero frequency or low
frequency
and now let's go to high frequency the
impedance gets high and it eventually
goes to infinity that's the impedance of
an open circuit so we say l
equals and open
at high f
high frequency and it's a short at low
frequency
let's do the same sort of jargon
investigation here for our capacitor
a capacitor at zero frequency has an
infinite impedance
so it looks like what it looks like an
open
at low frequency
so let's go look over at high
frequencies high frequencies the
impedance becomes very low
and at infinite frequency it becomes
zero and that's the impedance of a
perfect short
so the expression the slang expression
you'll hear is that a capacitor
is a short circuit
at high frequency
so the reason i'm telling you about this
very often experienced engineers will
talk to beginners
and use these kind of terms that oh an
inductor looks like a short at low
frequency and i wanted to show you where
these things come from where these terms
come from and what they mean and this is
this is not a simple idea you saw how
many assumptions we made and how much
work we did to get to this idea
of of these sort of
uh common or familiar expressions for
how our components work
i hope that helped for you to see how
how this comes about